[Música]
estos senderos causan hormigueos en las
piernas en Francia existen alrededor de
370 senderos gr o senderos de Gran
recorrido pero algunos de estos merecen
ser especialmente visitados
en la región de Bretaña en finista el
sendero de Luke se mezcla con la costa
atlántica una línea de tierra entre el
verde de los campos y el azul del océano
que inspira a muchos artistas
Stefany Nicolás son músicos locales y
buscan el lugar ideal para practicar
el entorno aquí es maravilloso
aún no hay mucha gente hace buen clima
nos dejamos llevar por el camino y por
el sonido de las olas
del oleaje
La gaita se llama minú la flauta es una
bombarda
[Música]
son dos instrumentos musicales
tradicionales de la cultura bretona muy
apreciados Por quienes pasean por full
you
[Música]
es una linda sorpresa
llegamos frente a esta Vista Hermosa y
de repente escuchamos el viñú estamos en
Bretaña hay una acústica natural en
estos paisajes
en estos caminos que es justamente lo
que buscamos el sendero es parte del
gr-34 el famoso Sendero de los aduaneros
que bordea la costa bretona luego llega
a la pequeña aldea de que arcele donde
parece que el tiempo se hubiera detenido
en 1889 Paul goup pintó estas casas modo
especialista en la vida del pintor
conoce esta historia de memoria Esta es
la granja que Selena allá vemos el horno
de pan que tenía un techo de paja
antiguamente la casa principal allá con
los postigos blancos también tenía un
techo de paja antiguamente
y el techo Azul la pintura se llama el
techo azul es la casa que está oculta
por los árboles que está justo detrás
mucho más al sur en las Sedena se
encuentra el gr 70 quien dejó su huella
en esta región no fue un pintor sino un
escritor en 1878 el autor de la isla del
tesoro
robertson emprendió una expedición de 12
días por este sendero acompañado de su
burra modeschin hoy el sendero lleva el
nombre del escritor y aún se ven burros
a lo largo del recorrido
la familia se prepara para embarcarse en
dos días de Aventura y unos 30
kilómetros de camino con esta guía de
cuatro patas es algo que queríamos hacer
desde hace unos años y nos dijimos
tenemos que ir tenemos que ir y aquí
estamos más de 6000 senderistas recorren
cada año el gr 70 sin contar los burros
pocos
minutos después de la salida el animal
les hace recordar rápidamente el
significado de una expresión más terco
que una mula
quiere pastar
a veces también quiere ir muy rápido
retenerlo
[Música]
viajar con un animal es una filosofía
diferente
los paisajes se descubren más lentamente
nos tomamos más el tiempo observamos más
las cosas
el hecho de guiar al burro también nos
frena un poco
vamos más despacio con el burro avanzar
despacio respirar aventurarse o Buscar
inspiración cada senderista tiene su
propia motivación en el gr 65 que
empieza en blueprint al sudeste de
Francia es más bien una búsqueda de
sentido lo que mueve a Max quien se
dirige a Santiago de Compostela con
otros 10 peregrinos hace años que tenía
esta determinación quería participar en
esta peregrinación
que para mí es tanto espiritual como una
búsqueda personal
todos tenemos algunos problemas en la
vida e intentamos encontrar respuestas a
preguntas esenciales incluso
existenciales
al igual que Max decenas de miles de
personas recorren cada año esta ruta la
vía pollosis declarada patrimonio de la
por la UNESCO es la ruta de
peregrinación francesa más popular hacia
Santiago de Compostela en España ven lo
que les estaba diciendo a lo largo del
camino de Santiago en cada Rincón en
cada jardín uno siempre encuentra cosas
curiosas como estos zapatos el camino
tiene su propio ambiente sus
particularidades y sus reglas como la
preciosa credencial del peregrino por
ejemplo un pasaporte que es sellado en
cada etapa al llegar al final del camino
es decir a Santiago de Compostela
Compostela Se expide una Compostela que
certifica que se ha recorrido todo el
camino la llegada
medieval emblemático de la ruta ya es
toda una recompensa después de 200
kilómetros y 12 días de caminata estoy
feliz lo logré no sabía si iba a ser
capaz de hacerlo y llega un sitio que es
todo belleza que es impresionante estoy
muy feliz a los pies de la famosa abadía
los peregrinos podrán disfrutar de un
merecido descanso antes de volver a
ponerse la mochila y emprender la ruta
por uno de los senderos más bellos de
Francia
[Música]